okay members it is six o'clock and we
are now live so everybody good evening
and welcome to tonight's planning
committee meeting my name is cancer
peter richards and i will be chairing
for uh tonight's meeting a few
housekeeping
things if i may to start with um we've
obviously heard a phone go off if you
could please turn your phones off or at
the very least silent um i don't mind
the being on but as long as they don't
disturb the meeting
uh please um i've already alluded to the
fact that we are live and being recorded
we will be streamed live to youtube and
our own uh
council website and it will be recorded
for later viewing and should anyone wish
to do so
a reminder to members of the public this
is a meeting in public
it's not a public meeting so only the
people that have registered to speak
will be permitted to speak
i will call on you at the appropriate
time when you leave your seats if you
could please put your masks
on and then come forward to this center
chair
uh there's some antibacterial wipes and
also some antibacterial and gel if you
could gel your hands
take a seat and we'll give you your time
and then whenever you're ready to speak
once you're done if you could then use
one of the wipes to wipe the table
and back your hands again refix your
mask in return that would be very much
appreciated
okay a few introductions um to my
immediate left we have our solicitor
ross
chambers to my immediate right we have
liz dwarska from committee services
uh we have a series of uh planning um
planners with us first of all joe brooke
who is in the chair now we also have
erin witherston and ryan o'keefe will be
joining us later on and we also have
tracy humphries who's
at the front here and i believe you
might have a statement for me thank you
chairman yes
just to tell members and members of the
public that i'm your planning manager
for the evening
and my role is to provide impartial
advice and to assist members
in your decision taking fabulous thank
you very much
let's dive into the full meeting agenda
then so first of all apologies for
absence please
thank you chairman we have apologies
from councillor curtis crump and
ed anderson fabulous thank you very much
members do we have any disclosures of
interests yes cancer fielding first of
all
um in that i have
been fishing and have met the
owner of the oakham farm
which is 2100 397
full um so those were some time ago but
i have
spoken to him at length at different
times
but not within the last four years are
you approaching this with an open mind
very that's what i want to hear thank
you very much um council jennings please
i'll be speaking on application two zero
zero three six three seven four um as
the ward member
thank you very much councillor mills
thanks mr chairman it's on the um
an item four on the agenda application
two one
oblique zero zero three four eight very
woodley house
i am the ward member for cayenneton i
will be speaking on that
um also speaking for a resident in the
kind and so i'll
step down from the debating table mr
lovely thank you very much if there are
no further disclosures we'll move into
that item
there are none okay in that case cancer
mills if you want to make your way into
the viewing gallery and we will start
with our first application which is
application 2100 348
very that is woodley house warwick road
in kington
our presenting officers joe brooke joe
over to you
thank you chair you just get the
presentation up
the site is located within
the site is located within the physical
confines of collington as indicated by
the black dot
for you the application relates
specifically to the variation of
condition numbers
two and nine the proposal seeks to make
revisions to the approved layout of
application
from the 2016 commission as indicated in
your report
in particular the variation is seeking
retrospective permission to relocate the
bin store to the north by 7.5 metres
so it's sited within a section of the
communal parking area
approved under the 2016 application
although some minor internal amendments
would also be permitted which are
detailed in the officer's report
the bin store itself is located at the
rear of the apartment's woodley house
and beyond the private garden areas the
bin store is constructed out of red
brick which faces onto the private road
and is a continuation of external brick
wall which contains the apartments
private gardens
where access to the bin store is located
wood fencing is located to the rear of
the bin store which has been erected
adjacent to the communal parking area
along the rear boundaries of the private
gardens
so with full reflection
this is now where the bin store is
retrospectively
positioned so it has been built out
there this is the parking area i'll go
back to the peru's plans
so originally it was approved there and
that was the original communal parking
area as per approved
this is a location of the bin store on
the elevations as indicated by the
outline red outline
this is woodley house going down the
woodstock road
warwick road apologies
that's the entrance to rio where the bin
store is located in the communal parking
area
so this is the road leading up to it
this is the continuation of the install
there as referred to in the report and
that slight entrance
entrance into the communal parking area
photo of the bin store and communal
parking area to the right
and this gives you an indication of 360
of the parking area
so she has laid out so that's the rear
they've been installed the wood fence in
woodley house adjacent properties and
the boundary wall in
and the neighboring web
that's the end of presentation in
consideration the area's development
plan national policy and guidance as
well as the relevant statutory
consultations the officer's
recommendation is on planning balance
approval
subject to recommended conditions as set
out in the office report
you will also see on the update sheet
the african has confirmed that parking
will retain
two disabled parking spaces thank you
chad
thank you very much joe um we will move
to it straight to our first speaker who
is councillor david gosling from kington
parish council good evening and welcome
i'll let you get settled before we move
on
so councillor gosling you'll have three
minutes we'll give you a 30 second
warning before you get to the end and
then obviously at the three minute time
as well
um there is a little button in the
middle of your speaker that will the
light will go red and we will be able to
hear you
whenever you're ready feel free to start
thank you good evening councillors and
officers um you're probably well aware
by now
of the attitude that kind parish council
holds to retrospective applications
which enabled developers to do what
they'd intended to do all along
but feared that they wouldn't get
through in the initial application and
we would really encourage the district
council to consider that retrospective
applications such as this one
should become subject to a penal charge
for submission
you might not be aware that when the
primary application was considered
many of the committee members visited
the site and agreed that access to the
rear car park was tight
and a disincentive to using it rather
than on street parking
this application only makes it worse
shaving all the additional spaces
all the additional space of the disabled
car parking space away
bringing forward the space opposite it
that intrudes further into the turning
space for a disabled driver
and shunting the six spaces along making
access to the non-existing
bike racks even less attractive the bin
area is smaller than the consented plans
delivered which is possibly why the two
conditioned 240 liter green bins have
not been provided
and by being smaller it makes it
extremely difficult for a single person
to move the 1100 litre bins out onto the
roadway
assuming they have the strength to pull
them across the loose gravel surface
to say that the latest design is more
logical
an improvement and without imposing on
the parking and i'm quoting from the
application
is to say the least inaccurate table
o three of supplementary planning
document um
requires a minimum car parking width of
2.5 meters
and a disabled space of 3.6 meters
all of the spaces in this retrospective
application are 2.4 meters
this application should not be
considered as a variation
it's retrospective and should be treated
almost as a new application
on that basis it fails to meet section
over the supplementary planning document
it also fails to meet section p which
requires bin storage areas
to be located within easy access for
residents
they have to leave the common cartilage
to get to the bin store
to have a solid floor i've already
mentioned the fact that it's loose
gravel
and that the door should be at least two
meters wide it doesn't appear to be from
those scale drawings that you've seen up
there
please refuse this application and
request that the conditions of the
consented development are complied with
including the bike rack thank you very
much
thank you very much councillor gosling
well within your time uh members do we
have any questions for the parish
council please
no in that case mr gosling thank you
very much if you could give it a quick
wipe
that'll be great thank you very much
so covered safe you can't even get in
marvelous
fabulous there's a bin just to the left
of you or to your right left or right
it turns out thank you very much indeed
our next speaker then
is mr mills welcome mr mills
so again following the same lines as
before you'll have three minutes we'll
give you a 30 second warning and again a
warning at three minutes whenever you're
ready mr mills please do start
thank you mr chairman um this is a
comment from mr mrs ari humphries
who have lived in seven woodley cottages
since a uh 1989.
this is the adjacent property bordering
the north side of the car park and the
shared war with the garden
of apartment 2. the business stories was
an issue in the first proposal and hence
there was an amendment to the initial
proposed plan by the high developers to
accommodate this the egyptian of the
surrounding residents to the approval of
the present
application for representative planning
of the bin eric
allocated is the unsightly and
inconvenient access to this area
the integrity of the ball has been
breached and the present
provision and present area is unfit for
purpose from a building regulation and
hygiene point of view
the opening for the bin area for the
residents of woodley house 10 apartments
should be from the car park side you
should have preferably have a door to
fully enclose it when completed
a suitable and able structure should be
a condition for the approval of the
reciting
from their previously approved scheme
the area is designated in the original
design is larger than the present area
proposed
it is a management it is immense and
manageable unmanageable disaster
waiting to happen in the future once the
410 apartments are occupied
picture the scenario two large black
wheelie bins two large blue wheelie bins
very little space for a green bin
provision and an attempt to move these
large bins in a limited space
the maneuvering of the bins at present
must be done on the thin gravel base and
wet clay soil
at present a strong and able resident
has volumes here to do this on behalf of
the residents of
of woodley house with some who are
elderly and quite frail
the residents of woodley house
apartments and surrounding community
deserve something better
from planning building regulations and
health and safety
we seek protection for by the control
and authorities of our district council
against poor quality
practiced by the developer thank you mr
chairman
thank you very much mr mills if you
would kindly wipe the table again for me
that will be greatly appreciated
fabulous thank you very much okay our
next speaker then is mr
chen our applicant mr chen welcome
come on forward
so i think you've got an idea of how
things going to work you're going to get
six minutes
um feel free to use as much or as little
as a bit as you like
uh we'll give you a 30 second warning
but otherwise whenever you're ready do
feel free to start
six minutes perfect you if you would
mind turning on your microphone
um that way the live stream will be able
to pick up your voice
that's it that's it you're on perfect
whenever you're ready
um dear committee my name is obergen and
i'm the applicant
i'm a family relative of mr hermann who
lived and worked in cottonton
for 30 years operating the former haven
house as a care home before retiring
he is the owner of the building as mr
hermann is in his late 80s and not in
the best of health
i was in charge of the development
following mr hermann's approval
of planning permission to convert the
building into 10 flats
it was during the construction phase
that i decided that moving the bin area
to its current location would improve
the quality and usable space
of flat 7 at woodley house without
moving the bin area
to where i did it would be oddly placed
within someone's garden
in a strange l-shaped form at least to
say
multiple bins would be closer to a
person's house
i moved the bin area in the knowledge
that it would cause no impact or harm
to the car parking area have no effect
on the number of car parking spaces
which is 10 the turning and maneuvering
of the cars
and of course the two disabled parking
spaces
there has been no impact to any car
parking numbering nor its layout
there has been no impact on the
usability of the bin area
the existing brick boundary and
ultimately
no difference whatsoever to any
neighboring properties
whether the bin area had been moved or
not
i've worked together with the planning
officer streets team
and environmental team to bring forward
a recommendation for approval i hope the
committee
can look at this reasonably and grant
approval for is clearly the correct
location
of the bin area absolutely nothing is
gained by moving the bin area
and it would only have a detriment
detrimental impact
on the garden and immunity space of flat
seven
thank you well within your six minutes
thank you very much members do we have
any questions for applicants cancer
jennings first
good evening um who's supposed to put
the large bins out
and why did you go for a loose gravel
instead of a
hard surface well the the truth is
i've been trying to get this application
uh in
since november 2020 i have no issues
whatsoever changing the
the flooring there to something harder
to make it easier
the reason the opening is on that side
is because it's much easier when the bin
when the bin men come to simply pull it
out of there if it was on the other side
internally through the car park you'd
have to maneuver it all the way around
so it doesn't make any sense to me again
if it's an issue
i can move it around but you know i can
change the flooring
i can change the door i can create a
larger opening the the only reason
um you know and and to anyone who asks
you know
what i mean i must be honest um
hindsight's an easy thing but i have
been trying to get this application in
since november
i'm under financial pressures i have
three young children
i'm going to stop you there you have
answered the question yeah sorry and
we're straying a little bit so we do
have other questions
to spare with councillor oh do you have
another one council jennings
you put your microphone on so the first
bit of the question was who's supposed
to put the bins out
the residents the residents yeah right
the the residents who live there
have for my feedback from them have no
problem with it i speak to them
i i don't want to dwell on this i
thought you said the bin men pull them
out
no no no the bins are pulled out i i
don't know exactly how it works
you know where i live that you pull the
bins out the bin then empty them put
them back to where you place them
and it goes back it's the easiest
location because the opening
for the bin area is right next to the
bins so all you'd have to do is put it
out about a meter
because the other way around you'd go
about six meters around okay
cancer failing next please um thank you
the inspecting the site yesterday
that the car parking area is gravel is
that
that's correct so therefore if the bins
was turned round you'd have to drag it
across the gravel
those those bins like i i
sorry just going back on the point that
i made before
the the development is not actually
finished because this has been hanging
on since november
so it wasn't it wasn't meant to be the
the car parking spaces are meant to be
numbered
lined out disabled parking but because
this is
still up in the air since november i
haven't had an opportunity to actually
finish it
okay yes because that's what i noticed
on site was that there were no car
parking numbers yeah and therefore you
couldn't see which were
the disabled partners that's appealing
just thank you but i think we cannot
probably ask questions to
our officers for detail about that um do
we have any other questions for our
applicants
no mr thank you i hope i got that right
yes thank you very much thank you for
your conclusion
okay our final speaker on this item is
councillor mills
council mills welcome back
you know the drill five minutes this
time 30 second warning whenever you're
ready
i shan't take your five minutes mr
chairman um
good evening committee um again this is
a classic case of yet another respective
planning application
when the redevelopment of the former
haven house was muted there were
apprehensions from the residents of
warwick road
and kind to parish council with the
concerns of parking problems
that this scheme would inevitably bring
to the residents along warwick road
this new application now looks to
reducing the parking spaces by
installing
this bin store this i'm sure would lead
to the residents of woodley house having
to park on warwick road drivers
will find these reduced parking spaces
will make it exceedingly difficult to
maneuver when trying to find a parking
space
which will inevitably lead to parking on
the warwick road which is ready under
pressure
with severe bark parking problems
the position of this bin store is also
questionable due to the fact is now
closer to woodley cottages
bringing up the the issue of hygiene and
the fact there is not a door on the bin
store
i know till i note also that the bin
store is now smaller than the original
plants make it problematic to
house four bins looking at the parish
council objections i agree that the bin
store will also have a detrimental
effect
on the ground floor apartments of
woodley house
i also ask why the bin store could not
be designed in such a way
so that residents of woodley house do
not have to enter the lane
to reach the bins should the committee
go for grant on this application can i
suggest that's the condition that the
access to the store be changed
instead of the access access as it is
reinstating them all breaking up the
access that it is
and repositioning the opening to the
short end of the bin store in the car
park
i don't know if we can i don't know if
joe has got a
a rear photograph of the actual bin
store they
wouldn't probably can't see it there
it's it's the bottom it's the bottom one
there
yeah anyway um
i mean if if the access could be made to
the short end
of the bin storage we can see it there
and and it is wide as well
uh that would be preferable and that's
what the applicant was saying
it looks like the floor the uh car park
is now going to be tarmacked and not to
be gravel but uh
i'll wait on that one um also this store
needs to have a
solid concrete base as as the applicant
has already said
because maneuvering the bins on gravel
is almost impossible
i know this as i've had the pleasure of
trying to pack the bins
into this very tight space the four
large
commercial bins two black and two blues
are very tightly crammed into into the
store and this is giving residents so
many properties in trying to get them
out of the store
a green bin will also be needed in the
future making it even worse
all in all i feel this retrospective
planning application is poorly designed
and will inevitably inevitably bring
with it several issues which could and
should have been avoided
i would leave this uh in the capable
hands of the planning committee mr
chairman thank you
thank you very much cancer mills members
do we have any questions for our
counselor
council dixon please thank you chairman
councillor mills um that's me
in requesting or in the idea of
moving the doorway or the access yeah
has been stored to the car parking side
yes
obviously we heard from the developer
um owner that his view was that he put
the doorway
so that the area to bring the bins was
that much shorter
if and you mentioned the fact that the
having to go into the lane
as a safety issue presumably if they've
been
opening is into the car park you'd still
take the bins to the
location where they're going to be
picked up you're still going into that
safety area and i wasn't concerned with
this with the
safety of going into the lane it was the
fact that uh
every time the uh residents have to
uh empty their bin into that big
commercial bin they have to go
you know take a long way around into the
um into the lane wasn't it wasn't the
safety issue
but i'm asking is if
the entrance to the bin store could be
made
on the short end of of that bin store
which will be wider that would be
preferable then we wouldn't have
um then you wouldn't the residents
wouldn't be looking on to
uh an open bin store for one thing um
and aesthetically it would look better
as far as i'm concerned there's no
safety issue
thank you okay do we have any other
questions from our members for
councillor mills no okay councilmembers
thank you very much if you give the
table a quick wi-fi i will do that mr
jim
thank you very much we will carry on um
so we moved to points of clarification
for our offices um council of fielding
first please
i would like to find out why it has
taken from november
until now to get to this position where
the developer can or has gone forward on
the scheme
what's been the delay
um on second comment uh
they've put in the application in the
last couple of months and we've
determined it
during the the time i i don't know the
answer to that
it's a development it's been putting
through a normal application
i can't remember the exact date it was
submitted um
but the honest truth is i i can't
comment on that
sorry i wonder whether it's relevant to
decision making and policy terms as well
joe we've also heard
um a couple of comments about the bins
how they're collected
that sort of thing do do you have any
understanding of how they might be
collected
um whether the residents have to
actually physically pull them out
whether that's down to the bin men
and if we were minded to grant would we
have the
ability to be able to add a condition
that says the floor of the
bin store needs to be tarmacked
on the first point i can't be a hundred
percent sure
what i do knows from correspondence with
sd street scene
they spoke directly with biffer and that
is in the report
and both of them were satisfied that
with the entrance and where it was
relocated they had easy access to it
now whether that means that yeah the
actual residents have to
go in and push it out i'm not 100 sure
i just know from the statute concept
where they're not statutory constitues
but i know from the relevant consultants
that they said
is adequate to get in and out of that
bin store for the bim men to pick it up
and unload okay great thank you i'm
sorry i need one second point tonight
on the house first so usually i'll be
honest with the hard service it would be
kind of covered on the building
regulations
that said it is operational development
i have noticed that on the plans
it's referred to as gravel so i do think
on this instance
especially regarding i mean it is for
the existing residents
i could do a notwithstanding condition
to put
a hard service area in there
lovely thank you very much um councillor
adam please
thank you um it was just in relation to
the um
width of the disabled spaces i think it
was the uh
parish council who raised concern over
that um and you've noted in the report
that they are
although they are being retained they
are reduced in width
and i i think this was from an spd a
requirement so
i suppose the question is i know there's
no highways objection but is this not
something that we would control
uh irrespective of that
the honest truth being it kind of comes
down to a balance and act with that on
planning balance as you noticed in the
report i have to refer to your qualities
act under 2020.
so the truth being is there is no
requirement
to have them disabled parking spaces and
of liaise with highways regarding this
so there are the opinion that the spaces
are sufficient to drive in and out of
including if they're disabled parking
as they are meant to be marked out on
the part and part o
it would make it very hard in my opinion
if we refuse it on the basis that you're
reducing disabled parking spaces
in regards to that there is still 10
parking spaces
the equality is that doesn't require
anything to be more than that
and highways have assessed the
dimensions turn and maneuver
and determine no ejection but i will
admit that the part o
does have a certain element to it it's
on planning balance i'll be honest
okay um last thing on that um do you
know what the actual dimension is for
for those disabled ones are they all the
same i think somebody suggested that
earlier one of the speakers
um i can't remember the top my head i
would have to check i don't want to say
no that's fine thank you
okay i don't think there are any more
questions for our officer however i can
see council mills frantically waving at
me
councilman before i call you forward i
just want you you'll know we have very
strict
rules around having a second bite of the
cherry so to speak i just want to check
that with my solicitor first
bear with me
um so if it's a clarification of a point
of fact
i'm happy for you to come forward
just a quick just to say that the the
bins themselves
are poured out by the residents
uh uh for the bifford to collect uh the
next
or that same morning uh i i did that
myself you know
pulling me out today but the residents
have to pull them out the biffa don't
pull them out
that's helpful thank you very much
okay i'm very sorry about the feedback
i'm not quite sure how to fix that if
i'm honest but we'll try and make do
um okay so we've had a point of traffic
is this a point of clarification
question dixon
try and get it in a bit quicker next
time if you would cancer dixon go thank
you chairman it was a question for joe
um in talking about the disabled spaces
there's obviously no
legal requirement to provide them
is uh it was the intention of the
original application
that car parking spaces will be
allocated to the individual flats
and if so were any of those flats
required to be
suitable for a disabled person if you
notice in the report i've followed over
one of the conditions where they're not
allocated to any individual flats so
they're all
um no allocations to it also from my
research the previous applications know
there was no requirements
for the disabled access as well it would
be under building regulations but under
planning considerations there was no
requirements that
should be disabled access and so forth
okay i think we're now done on points of
clarification who would like to kick off
the debate for me
before i pick on someone come on cancer
feeling
um i find it very hard to make
a strong decision on this because it
hasn't been finished
there is room for the developer
to amend it depending on
what we are talking about or what
conditions are imposed
i'm prepared to go for grant because i
believe
that the scheme is a good one i
understand the problem with regards to
disabled parking
but they can always be moved else or one
can always be moved elsewhere
there's no indication of at the moment
of where the bays are uh it's gravel
and i think that there is a lot of work
still to be done
and i'm i'm sad or
um that it's taken from november till
now
for this to be brought before the
committee
but however i would go for grant on it
and i propose that
the case okay thank you very much um you
heard earlier
i'm gonna move away from that slightly
um you heard earlier we talked about a
condition
for hard standing there do you want to
propose
that condition as well or is it just as
set out and i would like to propose
that the the hard standing
is conditioned is pumice and also i
would like to
make sure that the planning officer
works
to answer any conditional additional
conditions
we place on with regards to the opening
to the bins
store okay if
i'm not quite sure i follow what that
means but if we have any more conditions
he will
he's here um who would like to go next
council jennings please
yeah and i certainly think that if we're
going to
be granting this application that we
have to take
this hard standing into consideration
but i think as well
this hard standing needs to go almost
up to the road because if you're it's
all very well
pulling it out of that to the bin
storage room you've got to get it from
the bin storage room
onto the road and that again you can
pull it out and then just stuck
so if it's possible to condition
something where
it goes all the way to the road i'd be
more in favor of
of going with the ground okay um
so i'm gonna look to my uh officer for
some guidance on this i'm
looking at the picture on our screen now
i i i
think my understanding is correct that
that door backs onto the streets next
door so it's already tarmacked there
it's just what's inside that is
currently gravel is that correct
that is correct the second point being
we can only put conditions on within the
red line boundary because he's not in
the ownership
i i think that the point i was trying to
get to is i think within the red line
boundary which is
that we can just condition for the
internal of the
thing um hang on john uh council
jennings
given that are you happy to second the
proposal that's been made
i am great i think cancer kendall was
gonna do the same but he's
uh he's okay no one else wants to speak
over this side
cancer adam first just
wanted to sort say the the the speakers
against i i
accept the points that they've made i
think the trouble is i'm struggling to
find any
material reasons to go against and i
think granting with the conditions that
we've discussed allows us to at least
take control of this stage as a
committee
which will at least allow us to consider
their objections
within reason and do as much as we can i
think i agree with that cancer field
just quickly for hygiene reasons i don't
know whether
we can ask that a tap be placed in there
that would be a material change to
planning applications so no um
okay we have a proposal uh it has been
seconded that proposal is to grant with
the addition
of a condition it's not so easy to say
um
for hard standing within the bin store
we'll have a vote um all those in favor
please show now
believe that's unanimous fabulous thank
you very much in that case committee
uh grants application twenty one zero
zero three
four eight very magic thank you very
much
let's move on to our next application
which i've managed to misplace we do
need to uh call in our
next case officer so um we will just
take a very quick 30-second
break while while erin comes in
okay ernie you settled
thanks
okay so our next application is
application twenty one zero zero
three nine seven ful that is open
farm in loxley our presence officer is
erin williston erin over to you
thank you chairman
the application site lies to the
southeast of loxley village and
identified by the black dot on this plan
sorry about the feedback the site lies
outside of the settlement boundary
identified within the adopted ndp
and in the felden portland special
landscape area so it's just here
on the plan this slide identifies the
application site outlined in red
site comprises of a parcel of
agricultural land located to the north
of oakland coppice
here with the associated access from the
a429 to the east which is just here
the access currently serves fishing
lakes which you can see just here on the
drawing
agriculture buildings and holiday
lengths
public right of way sd80 follows part of
the access road
this section here is shown by the green
dash line
on this plan planning permission is
sought for the material change of use of
existing agricultural land
for the siting of clamping pods and
yurts and associated facilities
this slide is an aerial image of the
area the site is visible just here to
the left of the slide
in this location with the excess coming
through the coppice which you can see
here is a band of vegetation between the
existing buildings we've got the
agricultural buildings and the holiday
let's
the fishing lakes just here to the left
of the image along the access
back ta-429 this development includes a
communal pitching shower block
and proposed eight clamping pods and
yurts for seasonal use between the 1st
march and 30th of september each year
this slide shows a proposed site layout
you can see here
the clamping pods and yurts and the
communal kitchen and shower block just
here
in the center of the plan
this slide shows proposed access to the
site the top image
was taken close to the public highway
looking towards the site you can see
oakland coppice just here to the right
of the slide
top right image was taken looking along
the access point
again the couplers you can see just here
in the distance
the bottom left photograph was taken
looking along the access
the approximate location of the site is
just behind the coppers here where the
arrows shown
you see the existing buildings just here
to the right of the image
and the bottom right photograph on this
slide was taken
looking along the access where the
public right-of-way follows the access
point so just on a plan here
in this approximate location
this slide shows a number of photographs
taken on the approach to the glamping
site
see the existing agricultural buildings
just here to the right with a view from
the public right of way
the coppice to the rear and the holiday
light building to the left
this image just the top right of the
slide is continuing on the access
up towards the access to the clamping
site you can see the copper is here
the bottom left photograph is taken on
the access you can see the change in
ground levels
as it rises towards the sighting of the
camping pod
the clamping pods and yurts and the
bottom right image
was taken looking back towards the
existing buildings from the access
this light had a number of photographs
taken from this section here of the site
sorry other feedback so this first
photograph is taken looking back towards
the access
and we're just trying to swap a
microphone out that's pretty bad sorry
everybody uh
we'll try and swap it out i think just
to be on the safe side there's a bunch
behind you
is that better perfect thank you thank
you
so just to start with this slide the top
image was taken looking towards the
access you can see just here
of the application site panning around
towards the south you see the existing
coppice
next photograph is panning around again
and the final one
panning around the site in the
approximate locations of the arrows to
the bottom
of the site and the photographs on this
slide were taken from the northeast
corner of the application site
approximately in this location
looking across the site at the existing
vegetation
and boundary treatments looking back
towards the corpus and looking towards
the west there are a number of updates
which have been circulated on the update
sheet
it's recommended that planning
permission be refused for the reason set
out in the officer report
thank you thank you very much again um
okay
our first speaker on this item is mr
brian barrow um sparrow welcome good
evening
are you only a yard away i'll let you
off
strictly speaking we should make sure
our master run but
okay so mr barry you have three minutes
we'll give you a 30 second warning
before your time is up otherwise
whenever you're ready feel free to start
thank you chairman this proposal is for
glamping tents and structures as part of
a farm diversification project
the farm already has holiday lets and
will provide more varied accommodation
and allow for add-on services
the farm is 120 acres and runs a flock
of 200 sheep which is small scale
in modern agricultural terms there are
aims to add more animals such as pigs
and involve
visitors in the on-farm experience this
would involve lambing and feeding of
animals as well as enjoying the numerous
flora and fauna present
the farm is well certified footpaths as
you have heard giving access to the
wider countryside
the officer's report outlines no
particular planning issues from the
consultations with no objections
yet recommends refusal due to
sustainability and the use of cars
this flies in the face of government
advice to encourage rural businesses
and uses local planning policy which
predates the nppf
and i feel needs broader interpretation
in these changing times
the report suggests the facility will
not relate directly to any tourist
facility
but fails to recognize that the
countryside is in itself
a tourist facility and in this case the
owners wish to open up the farm to
visitors to enjoy the rural on-farm
experience
there is a good network of footpaths to
allow access to local facilities
such as the pub which you can walk
directly to
it is worth stressing that there are 63
800 tourist related businesses in rural
areas
employing 0.6 million people that was
pre-covered
to suggest everyone has to stay in towns
and urban areas and to reduce
car use makes no sense as these people
need to travel
out into the countryside it is evident
following the current crisis that many
visitors will avoid crowds for some time
to come
so rural tourism is likely to be more
popular but only if the facilities allow
the sensible approach is a mix of
facilities so visitors can choose the
appropriate accommodation for their
needs
those wanting to see the stratford sites
will stay in or around the town
those wishing to enjoy the countryside
or country walks will choose the
countryside
glamping provides an ideal bridge
between
formal hotel and guest accommodation and
camping
it has enabled a much greater proportion
of the population to experience the
countryside
and especially during current
circumstances is an excellent way for
visitors to feel safe in their own
defined space
this application doesn't have to be
refused as the government advice can be
followed to support
its efforts to diversify 30 seconds
sustainability is not just about
car use it is has three objectives
social economic
and environmentally this scores highly
because it meets the demand for this
type of accommodation
and allows more to people to enjoy the
countryside and economically it supports
for small farm business
with many foreign holidays off the
agenda what better way to encompass a
sustainability
and i'll finish for those who follow bbc
radio and online you will have noticed
today's camping campaign
and this fully embraces that concept
thank you
marvelous thank you very much just dead
on three minutes well done
uh members do have any questions cancer
fielding
the document provided by the officer
refers to the fact that um
mr hudson deals with a shooting
matter we've also got the fishing is
this sort of
part and parcel with the leisure
activities that are
you're referring to within the
application
yes it would be obviously uh when
somebody comes to stay on the farm the
farm facilities you've got such as the
fishing and things like that
the other things that people can enjoy
when they're there and obviously
providing accommodation alongside those
facilities allow those people to
to join things together you know i
certainly have a client down in kent who
has a caravan site with fishing legs and
it's busy all the time a lot of
fishermen obviously bring their caravans
to
to do the fishing so they they don't
travel off site so much because
everything's there for for what they
want to do
thank you very much councillor to
council philly are you turning
microphone off please cancer failing
john thank you councilman thanks
um could you just tell me in your view
would this develop mean
that the scale in which you think this
development would
form in as part of your your land
small medium large sort of development
well it's it's relatively small scale
because there's only nine
um nine um pods or or cabins
and basically each one would tend to be
occupied
by a couple or a small family so you
know compare that to a
you know a guest house or hotel it would
be a relatively sort of
small to medium guest house with nine
nine bedrooms it's not a
you know 40 50 60 bedroom hotel by any
means
and and i suppose in in terms of the the
land that it occupies in relation to the
rest of the farm is that
it'd be relatively small it'd be
probably less than one percent i would
have thought
okay thank you very much thank you
cancer fleming please
ah thank you and the impact
is it going to be seen from i mean it
looks to be very well screened obviously
with the cops and whatever
but i just wonder what visual impact
from sort of
other viewpoints around the area yeah as
the officer outlined uh
there's there's trees around virtually
all sides you can see from
the photograph that it is a field that
is actually
you know unusually surrounded by trees
it's a it's an ideal
location uh when you're looking at these
sorts of
projects actually finding a good
location can be difficult but here
you've got an ideal
location because you've got all of that
screening
okay thank you very much thank you very
much jennings please
yes so just a quick bit of clarification
on this i presume
the idea is when they when they arrive
they'll park at the farm
and then walk out or will they drive
onto the field generally it varies in my
experience but quite often obviously if
ground conditions allow you drive out
and park next to your
next to your pod but or equally they can
park in the in the farmstead and
and walk out so there's options
lovely thank you no one has any
questions i'm just going to follow up on
something that cancer filling said
earlier about the existing businesses
did you say that there are existing
recreational
activities happening on the farm yes as
i understand it they have
they have fishing fishing facilities and
obviously there is a
the footpath that we heard about
actually links directly to the pub i
think if you actually walk down it it's
10 minutes and you arrive at the pub
so um you know basically they've got a
lot of things on the doorstep
and and just to be clear they are
commercial businesses they're
just since i understand it yes lovely
thank you council voting did you have
another question don't feel that you
have to
no good man miss barrett thank you very
much if you wouldn't mind giving the
table well you're already on it good man
and if you could fix your mask
before you go back i'd be grateful yep
thank you thank you very much
okay honest speaker counselor o'donnell
come on down
good evening and welcome council donald
now you know the drill you have five
minutes we'll give you a 30 second
warning
whenever you're settled and ready to go
do feel free to start
thank you um just one clarification
about the parking there's hard standing
in the corner of the field so they can
park there and walk across to the
to the pods um so committee there is no
denying that camping has a certain type
of romance to it
from reconnecting with nature and
building a campfire to sit around
to watching the sunrise from a tranquil
setting there are many better feelings
than getting back
to life's basics but traditional camping
holidays aren't always just a turn up
and sort of get away
you'll pile the car high with camping
gear pitch your tent fight with the
family
and maybe suffer a cold and
uncomfortable night's sleep a glamping
holiday
on the other hand offers all the upsides
of the outdoorsy holiday in an easy
comfortable and
stress-free way call it glamorous posh
or luxury camping it's still camping
just with some of the comforts of home
and it's just what we need in loxley
because of the fourth worst hit district
in the uk as we emerge from the pandemic
we need to establish a multi-layered
tourism offer for all budgets and
tastes especially with the staycation in
mind and attracting uk citizens
from both surrounding areas and further
afield and glamping in loxley does
just that the site is just up the road
from childcare house and childcare mill
and from the new community pub which is
getting a lot of mentions tonight the
fox
at loxley which will benefit from all
local tourism endeavours
the roads are easy and safe to navigate
and really popular with walkers due to
the fact that you truly feel you were in
the heart
of the beautiful english countryside
with only the hum of light aircraft from
the airfield close by
to remind you you're just a step away
from civilization
if we look at this application with
regard to the nppf
paragraph 83 and 84 give policy on
supporting a prosperous rural economy
and you'll know committee that i fight
hard to support our rural enterprises
which usually struggle with
infrastructure and broadband but
that doesn't matter in this case because
it's the self-contained aspect of the
proposal which makes it so
suitable paragraph 83 states that
planning policies and decisions
should enable the sustainable growth and
expansion of all types of businesses in
rural areas
both through conversion of existing
buildings and well-designed new
buildings
they should enable the development and
diversification of agricultural and
other land-based rural businesses
and finally enable sustainable rural
tourism
and leisure developments which respect
the character of the countryside
this does all of the above paragraph 84
goes on to state
planning policies and decisions should
recognize that sites
to meet local business and community
needs in rural areas
may have to be found adjacent to or
beyond existing settlements
and in locations that are not well
served by public transport
you don't want to wait to catch the bus
when you're glamping you'll be walking
cycling or perhaps driving but you will
be self-sufficient
otherwise you would pick a city break
it's important to recognize that the
core thread of the nppf
is sustainability for which there are
three dimensions in planning terms
the economic objective the social
objective and the environmental
objective
these three objectives cannot be taken
in isolation
economic growth can secure higher social
and environmental standards
and well-designed buildings and places
can improve the lives of people and
community
it is clear from national policy that
both tourism
and diversification are supported in the
countryside
it is also important to remember that
the site will be a change of use of the
land
only which can currently be undertaken
up to 56 days a year
as permitted development with no control
from the local planning authority
no permanent buildings are proposed
although the kitchen and shed pods
will remain in situ as a use of the land
there are no adverse impacts of this
application committee
camping glamping sites are socially
sustainable
they encourage social interaction and
encourage a wide range of people
from all ages and different social
backgrounds to mix together
the site is well screened with mature
trees and hedgerows which will mitigate
any visual impact
and due to the limited number of places
available additional traffic movements
will be limited
farm diversification is supported in
planning policy
and the proposal will assist the
applicant in improving
the tourist income from the farm which
will complement the existing holiday let
this is a family who are valued and
respected within the community
the parish council support was strong
and we need to nurture our rural
enterprises
and support our farmers whose resilience
is legendary
so i urge you committee to see logic and
grant permission
thank you very much councillor members
do we have any questions for councillor
o'donnell please
council feeling a little bit of a loss
with regards to the
transport you're saying that the they're
going to be parking their cars at the
farm
and then walking up no i'm saying the
field that you have up there there's a
there's a
area of hard standing is my
understanding and that's where they will
park
across john john if you remember to turn
your microphone off you'll be able to
hear
perfect thank you so there is a there's
an area of hard standing
in the field where the pods will be and
they will park there and it's a short
walk to their individual pods or arts
whatever they're going to be called
take it that's where the bins and
everything else will be
um i presume that's the case i think
aaron could clarify that for you
yeah we'll we'll ask aaron to do that
shortly any further questions for cancer
donald no castle donald thank you very
much
if you could wipe the desk you're
already on it and re-fix your mask
before you leave that'll be great
okay let's move to point clarification
erin we've already had one if you could
tell us about bins
that would be great so as part of the
development highways has recommended a
waste management plan as we'd be
recommending a condition for the details
to come in if
members were minded to support the
application lovely thank you very much
council dixon
thank you chairman erin on page 19
part s of policy as 10
supports small scale tourism
a couple of sentences further on in your
opinion i consider that the use would
represent a medium scale
development we're talking about i think
eight
pods from the update sheet rather than
nine
would six be small scale would 15 be
large scale are there any definitions in
our policy or is this
purely a personal opinion so we do have
guidance set out in part k of the sbd
which relates to
um sorry caravan and holiday leds
and it sets out what you normally expect
number of factors for small scale medium
scale and large scale schemes
and in medium scale you look at the
number of units it's seasonal use but
it's where you're looking to provide
facilities such as power and water which
is
in in this case and you're looking to
have yurts and caravans
and motorhomes those sort of elements um
that's where
it would then tip it over so in this
case it's considered to be medium scale
based on those factors in office's view
counselor adam please thank you
um councillor dixon asked what i was
going to ask to a certain extent
um and i was wondering if uh following
on from that if there was any sort of
flexibility in your in
definition but i've got to follow up
with them as well i mean in terms of the
guidance it sets out a table with
um a different small medium and large
and that's how officers that we've used
that guidance in this case and come to
that conclusion it's medium scale
um i suppose the the following um
question i was going to have which was
in relation to how relevant it is
this development is to um
tourist and leisure attractions um i
think on page 19 you've
made reference to cs24 where it says
proximity to
any relevant tourist or leisure
attractions um but that on the
then on the following page you say that
it's
not uh relating directly to any major
existing tourist
um attraction it's just seeing where how
firm it is on
on on the size and scale of attraction
and whether
as the applicant describes the the local
more agricultural rural base of
attraction
would count under the previous
definition so policy cs24 relates to
tourism and leisure development
and it talks about small-scale tourism
and visitor-based schemes but it also
talks about large-scale visitor
accommodation where
you've got um a major existing tourist
recreation conference or other form of
business use
so that's what the policy cs24 talks
about when we're looking at tourism
ledger development so that's why in this
case it's not considered to meet that
part
okay any further points clarification
council fielding i'm just taking up on
what was said about cs24
um impact on the character of the
landscape
and settlements well you can't see it
um the benefits that uh
john is it's a point of clarification
what is this a point of clarification
because it sounds like you're moving
into the debate
ah okay well i'll just if you if you
want to move in
john before john if we carry on if you
want to move into debate we can do that
now and we can carry on
uh but if it's a point of clarification
we need a question
council mills thanks richard um erin
i lost that last part are you are you
saying this is
too too small uh
attraction so it's gonna benefit the
area
so in terms of the the proposal we've
been looking at um
any major existing tourist or recreation
facilities at the largest scale
um in terms of the policy in this case
it's not considered to be small scale in
officer's view so it doesn't appear to
meet the policy
when we're looking at being linked to a
major tourist attraction
right thank you i think i understand
that you know
okay i think we're done with points for
clarification let's move into the debate
john would you like to start us off
given this you were prepared
i'm just looking through
cs24 the benefits that this scheme
offers to the local communities the pub
the shops
the benefit the scheme should secure the
wider economic
and environmental interests goes down
into the village of um
impact the character the landscape will
hardly say that a few
eight camping pods are
really going to make much of a thing
when it's so well
hidden um the nature of the existing
site in its relation to the local area
um it is an agricultural farm it is very
much into the
agricultural side and i feel very feel
that um
that's with regards to as10 small-scale
tourism
visitor accommodation leisure-based use
including sports and recreation
particularly as those that would help to
provide local employment
and supporting areas proposed building
a visitor accommodation is directly
associated
the the two policies that you refer to
i can't see why you are
don't want to grant this application and
it's particularly with your definition
of small
scale and to compare it with caravan
park i think is
is wrong this is a totally you can't do
it's not like for like
this is a an event in the countryside
which is there to offer
leisure and open air and
basically pleasure for a number of
people
thank you cancer fielding i have three
speakers registered i will take them in
the order in which they signal to cancer
mills first please
yeah thanks mr chairman um i have to say
council o'donnell does paint a
a rosy picture of um what is proposed
here
um how to smile at that um
for my mind i mean there's
only eight glamping pods and
a couple of yurts it took to my mind
it's not harming the countryside it is
surrounded as counterfeiting set by
trees um it is acquired
quite close to all the attraction that
stratford-upon-avon uh has to offer
uh close to the the pub um
personally i think it's quite it was
quite a nice uh
scheme this mr chairman and um
i'm all for it thank you very much is
that a formal proposal yes mr chairman
marvellous we'll have to come back for
a bit more detail in a second but we'll
do that shortly cancer adam please
thank you um i can see where the
officers coming from i've quickly
checked um
part k for the spd to see where the
scale thing came from because we're
wondering what what we could do with
that
i'm i'm broadly in support of this and i
think that there may be enough wiggle
room that we can
support it within within what they've
sort of looked at
because i think ultimately we are
looking at a diversification of the
business
um in a rural location that will be
beneficial to
the area and i think we should
as a council be be fully supportive of
that so i'm very happy to second
uh on that basis um exactly how we sort
of get through the
the um the the core strategy spd
um as well to get there i'm sort of
trying to
formulate but um but happy second for
now
thank you very much cancer kendall
please thank you i won't delay the
committee too long i think i'm broadly
in
agreement with the previous two speakers
councillor o'donnell does paint an
extremely attractive view of this i
think she's uh
selling me like immediately actually a
book up right now
um so i i actually think that i
understand completely where is coming
from in terms of
the medium scale there's a set of
criteria and she's applying those
properly i get that
however i do think that this does offer
significant benefits to
the local community and the wider
district so i'll be supporting
the recommendations steph has stated so
far
fabulous thank you very much councillor
jennings and
to me they this site already has
commercial use
and i think that's sort of an important
factor here um this
could be regarded as an extension of an
existing business
um the fact that they're going to be
there for seven months
and then they're gone and then it's it
is back to countryside i mean i think
we need to support local businesses how
in every way shape or form we can covid
has
has changed the goal posts and it will
continue to have an effect for a long
for many years to come and we need to
encompass and support rural businesses
in any way shape or form we can
fabulous thank you very much um okay i
think i will very quickly sum up
um and continue to telephone well after
i've summed up i think
um so we have a proposals grant it's
been seconded i think the reasons that
have been given
are that um the it appears to be an
expansion of an existing business i
completely agree with that and that's
the way i'm looking at it
therefore would accord with as10 and
cs24
it also provides significant benefit to
the community direct community but also
the wider community
in terms of its tourism and the leisure
facilities is that a fair summation
yes yes i'm seeing lots of nods okay on
that basis then i think
we need to look at conditions um do you
have a list of proposed conditions for
us please
erin yes i do um just sort of summary
but in terms of the works
um it'd be three years approved plans
limit the sighting
of the pods on the yurts um in terms of
where they are on the site with one
facility's building
a number of pods and yurts and
facilities building seasonal use only
with the elements to be removed when
they're not in use as proposed as part
of the application
holiday use only not for a main
residence
finish of the detail to be provided a
landscaping condition the waste
management
plan and parking to be agreed by
condition
and service runs and details for the
power and water that's going in
marvelous to our proposal and saying
that are they happy with that do you
want to add anything else
no perfect counselor servant given where
we're at in the committee in the
direction do you still feel the need to
speak
yes chair i was i was going to just
support all the speakers previous i
think it's a good idea
lovely stuff in that case let's move to
a vote the proposal is the grant for the
reasons given
and the conditions set out if we could
have a show of hands for those in favor
please
chairman thank you very much that is
unanimous therefore committee results
to grant application 21 0 00 397 ful
open farm in loxley can we sign
country o'donnell up for any uh sales
pitches we should do
yes
okay right let's move let's move to our
thank you very much members let's move
to our next item
uh which is application 2100 356 rem
london buildings at the rear of japonica
in
southam our presenting officers once
again aaron wilson and as soon as you're
ready aaron
do feel free to start
thank you chair
the application site lies the west
surprise martin village as identified by
the black dot on this plan
just here prize martin village is
identified as a category four local
service village within the council's
adopted call strategy
and the site falls within the draft bill
to parry boundaries for the settlements
this slide identifies the application
site outlined in red
just here site comprises a parcel of
land with a lawful commercial planning
use
an existing vehicular access from
southern road just here
public right of way sm-98 follows the
access route of the site with its
approximate location shown by the green
dash line
heading here to the north the site lies
in part within the conservation area
which is shown by the pink line on this
plan
you can see the overlay here this
section is in the conservation area
then it goes up to the east of the site
there are a number of grade two listed
buildings to the south of the site which
front the southern road
which is shown here in red
there are three buildings within the
application site larger building here
and two smaller brick buildings here
this building and the smaller red brick
building is proposed to be demolished as
part of the works
outline planning permission was granted
in 2018 reference 1800
525 out the erection of four open-market
dwellings
and the demolition of the two buildings
on the land this application seeks
approval of the reserve matters
including the access
appearance landscaping layout and scale
of the development pursuant to condition
four of the outline permission
this slide shows an aerial image of the
area the site is located
close to the center of the image you see
the existing buildings here
and the access from the southern road
that follows through and rounds
and the two buildings just mentioned
with access provided through to
neighbouring properties
here which bunk the southam road
neighbouring properties can be seen here
to the west in gradual close
to the east the front the holloway and
to the south at front the southam road
this slideshare is a proposed site
layout development includes
four two-story detached dwellings which
have been arranged along the northern
edge of the vehicular access
you can see just here all plots have got
separate parking areas
and the garden area is largely to the
rear of the built form
development seeks to use existing access
from the southern road
and and retain the public right of way
along its existing alignment
you see just going up here and it being
closed by a closed border defense for a
stretch of approximately 50 metres from
this point here
up into the countryside the existing
trees which are on the site you can see
just in this location here
will be retained as part of the
development and new planting including
native species hedgerow planting
and new trees is proposed along these
boundaries close boarded fencing is
proposed between the plots
and a red brick wall is proposed here to
provide privacy for plot four
the existing building which is proposed
to be retained will be used for
ancillary residential purposes
this slide has proposed elevations for
the new dwellings the dwellings will all
be three bedroom properties with
associated living accommodation
key features include gable features and
projections
you see just here two story elements
and the properties will be finished in
horns and stone with brick features
under slate roofs
the ridge height of the dwellings varies
from approximately 8.9
closest to bradshaw close across to
eight meters to the east of the site
where you've got plot four
this slide has a number of photographs
taken from within the application site
the top left was taken looking in a
western direction from within the site
dwellings on fragile clothes are visible
just here in the backdrop of the image
the top right was taken panning around
the application site you can see the
outbuilding here
towards gradual close and the public
right of way long
runs along the boundary just here the
bottom left photograph was taken from
within the application site from the
access road and see the existing
buildings proposed to be demolished
enabling properties that front the
holloway to the east visible in the
background of this photograph
this final photograph was taken on the
site from the public right of where you
can see just here
looking back towards the application
site with the existing building on the
site visible just to the left of the
image
this slide shows a couple more
photographs from within the application
site
taken from further within the site see
the existing building here and bradshaw
close
just to the left of the image panning
around you see the existing building
and the out building of the neighbouring
property and as you move across looking
eastwards you've got the outbuilding the
neighboring property
going towards looking towards here the
properties that front the holloway
this final image on the slide shows the
two buildings on site the building
that's proposed to be retained show to
the right
this slide shows the access to the
application site
the first image top left is taken
looking out towards
the road with gradual close properties
visible just to the right of the slide
of the photograph the next photograph at
the top right was taken from the
southern road looking back towards the
application site
of the existing access the bottom
photograph was taken from the
application site looking towards
bradshaw clothes
and the bottom right photograph was
taken looking back towards the village
from the application site access
this slide shows a number of photographs
or dwellings within the locality of the
site
top left image shows photograph of
bradshaw clothes and the dwellings that
lie
close to the application site the top
right photograph was taken along the
hallway showing properties that
lie to the east of the application site
got another photograph of the closest
neighboring property you can see just
taken here from the southern road
and the final photograph on this slide
was taken
from the southern road looking towards
the grade two listed dwellings and the
terrorists of properties located to the
south of the application site
approximately in this location here
there are a number of updates for this
application which have been circulated
on the update sheet
including amendments to the proposed
conditions it is recommended that
reserve matters application be approved
for the reason set out in the officer
report
thank you thank you very much we will go
to our first speaker who is a councillor
dunkley from prize martin parish council
good evening
thank you very much for putting your
mask on
i think you've got an idea of the drill
by now so you'll have three minutes with
a 30 second warning
take your time to get settled and
whenever you're ready do feel free to
start
okay um while the parish council
themselves don't have any objections to
the redevelopment of the area it's a bit
of wasteland and putting some houses on
it we don't have any objections in that
regard
we do however feel that the access road
in and out
doesn't provide uh sufficient vision
splays when coming in and on
in on and off the southern road in
addition there isn't any pedestrian
access into the village so anybody
coming in would either have to climb
across the two stars that were indicated
in one of the photographs
or walk along the narrow road which was
in the bottom
right hand set of photographs there
which is where the road narrows
the size and scale of the houses going
into the
the volume if you like of the house on
each individual plot
is such that the road within the within
the plot itself
isn't is just as narrow as the access
road meaning
if anybody doesn't park in a designated
parking space then there's no access for
the uh
fire tender to be to get in or out or
even maneuver
um and so on those basis
we would object lovely thank you very
much
very much inside your time uh members
have any questions
please the parish council no in that
case
council dunphy thank you very much for
your contribution if you wouldn't mind
wiping your desk very quickly for me
if you could turn the microphone off as
well that would be great lovely thank
you very much
okay our next speaker is mr john clark
mr clark
welcome come on forward
while you're settling yourself i'll just
remind you of three minutes 30 second
warning and when you are settled
whenever you're ready do you feel free
to start
thank you chairman members officers for
this opportunity to speak this evening
i act on behalf of the applicant as the
planning agent
i don't want to duplicate anything which
has already been said
by your officer i just want to clarify
a few points and comment on the three
points
raised by the parish council first of
all
the access road and vision displays
the scheme complies with the
requirements of the highway authority
as we're set out on the outline planning
commission
and meets the highway authority
requirements secondly
no pedestrian access i'll disagree
there's a public footpath which runs
down the
access road that's going to be improved
as part of the scheme by providing a
defined
way and there's no difference between
the existing use and the
proposed in terms of accessibility into
the village
thirdly the size and scale of houses
the road is too narrow within the site
parking has been provided
we've provided tracking details it meets
the highway authority requirements
i'd have to disagree with that comment
the principle of the development of the
site for housing has been established
through the outline planning commission
um i'm pleased to see there's no
technical objections from any of your
consultees
um extensive supporting information has
been submitted in support of the
application including
drawings a road safety audit
architects drawings a heritage statement
and a tree report the design of the
houses
responds to local character and at three
bed
there of an appropriate size for both
the site
and the character the village i
therefore
ask members to follow your office's
recommendation
and approve the reserve matters thank
you
mr clark thank you very much members do
we have any questions from us clark
please our agent because of feeling
internal road is there room if required
to widen it to give more uh
access for emergency vehicles
uh through you chairman an answer to
that um the layout meets the highway
authority requirements for
emergency access and access to the
houses there's no need to do that
thank you very much anyone else have a
question for mr clark no in that case mr
clark thank you very much for your
contribution this evening
if you could please refix your mask and
wipe the desk before you leave that
would be great
i can see a hand up in the audience i'm
sorry this is there's no uh public
participation other than those
registered to speak
you are forgive me um before
before you do sorry are we it is a point
of clarify
clarification on point of fact is it a
clarification of a point of fact
before hang on i don't want to debate
between the two of you um
mr clark if you want to wipe the desk
down and return to the to your seats
yeah i will get to that um
it does need to be a very clear point of
fact in order for you to have a second
chance to speak
can you confirm to me that it is a clear
point of fact
if you would like to put you if you
could refix your mask
and come to the desk and tell me what
that point of fact is
mr clark in as a procedure
in order to ensure fairness if
what we hear now is not a point of fact
it will be disregarded or if you need to
come back i can ask you to come back
um the comment made about the footpath
we have no objections of the footpath in
and out of the development
it's the footpath into the village
itself that we objected
we know there's a different path in out
the development and that's fine okay
understood
i don't think there's a need to come
back on that so we will proceed as
per our normal procedures okay
um council rock did register to speak
but sadly can't be with us tonight
so i have a script from him so i will
read that now forgive me i am reading it
directly so apologies if
i i'm not looking at you while i do um
so council rock has said i believe that
this design is compressed in the context
of the plot with oversized dwellings and
compromised
access considerations the outline
permission required
that the dwellings that the dwelling be
very small scale and modest to reflect
the size
scale and character of the existing
properties nearby
no numerical size was specified but the
average uk home according to the bbc
is 85 square meters and the average new
home in the uk
is 75 square meters it is axiomatic
that a very small home would be less
than that
plot 1 and 2 are 140 square meters the
other two similarly sized
houses that are nearly double the
national average cannot possibly be
considered to meet the terms of the
outline permission of a very small
scale i observed that a vehicle tracking
analysis
has been made has been made because of
the marginal turning areas
it is essential that vehicles exit the
site forwards
the analysis shows that it is
theoretically possible for a skilled and
careful driver to turn
using the full turning capabilities of
the vehicle however we all know
there has been a change in patterns in
home deliveries over the couple of years
with three and a half ton vans often
being used in my experience careful and
skilled
are not words that always apply drivers
often find it more convenient to reverse
out of such private driveways
rather than take the trouble to turn
unless this is really necessary
after considerable debates wcc have
withdrawn their objection to the highway
access
subject of his visibility displays being
provided
i have looked at this carefully measured
division display length required and
can't see how these can be achieved
the permission would require the cutting
back of existing vegetation apparently
in the ownership of third parties
on close examination of the hedgerows it
seems to me that the cutting back
required goes beyond the root line and
beyond a boundary fence
to the adjacent properties i can't read
what
the adjacent properties called but to
the adjacent properties
also i find i'm in disagreement with the
report in that i believe the damage to
the hedgerows would be
visually unacceptable and unreasonably
dependent on continuous
seasonal cutting back removal of the
hedges would have an unfavorable
and un an urbanizing effect on the rural
location
i also can't see how it is legally
possible if others own
the hedges and that is verbatim council
rocks submission
okay clearly i can't ask questions uh
answer questions on behalf of council
rock so we will move to points of
clarification
councilor mills first please thanks
richard um
erin the uh some
objections there are the height of the
um proposed development
are they higher than say branch or close
it was assessed as part of the
application so in terms of the heights
does vary across the site reducing down
to plot four
and we did have plans submitted with the
application to show
heights of bradshaw clothes so i'll just
see if i can find that
plan for you but in terms of the heights
on fragile clothes
um
the plan that's been submitted makes
reference to number four bradshaw
clothes having a ridge height at
point i'm sorry 8.94 um
number eight at 8.07 and looking at the
other properties so what we're looking
at here
is 8.9 to the highest point and so
in terms of the height of the properties
on bradshaw close there are some taller
properties
and as you look to the east of the site
you've got more one and a half story
properties
fronting the holloway if i just bring up
the plan so there's a mix of heights in
the street scene but there has been a
comparison submitted
and the heights gradually reduce as you
go across the site closer to the hallway
where you've got
lower height properties oh i see so
they're um the heights bury them
across the the plot yes across the
application site so in terms of the
heights
you've got the taller properties located
to the west of the site and then they
reduce down in ridge height
as you get closer to the east of the
site and so the heights then vary
between
8 and nine meters to the ridge
so so they are
you know because they vary they're some
are some aren't higher than
branch or close yes
so in terms of gradual close there are a
number of different heights the tallest
one is number four which is
um been scaled and it's 8.94 so we've
got 8.9 on the application site for the
tallest part of the ridge heights
thanks eric and mr kai as far as
the visibility display uh is concerned
on that uh on the entrance you're saying
the the hedges are going to be cut
back that's correct yes
who do they belong to these hedges as
part of the assessment
and we did have a road safety audit
submitted with the application which
made recommendations to
cut the hedgerow back to provide the
visibility displays how he said query
the ownership and then there were
satisfied and recommended conditions
it's my understanding it falls within
the highway
verge thanks very much
can i one more and i
i i drove up this
foolishly in my car driver drove up this
uh road um
and he's quite narrow and can it take
mr sainsbury's lorry
and can he turn around up there we have
had tracking plans submitted with the
application
um which were considered by highways and
fire and rescue as well which
satisfied their sufficient space coming
into the site to turn in the turning
heading come back
out in terms of the width it's
approximately 3.7 for most of the access
road
and it is wider um i think it's five
meters for the first ten meters back
from the highway in this section here
which will allow vehicles to pass oh
right thanks thanks harry super thank
you
thank you very much council adam please
thank you
uh councillor mills did ask one of the
points i was going to
uh ask i was going to ask something else
um
it was in relation to the scale um that
counselor rock raised in his um
submission um
and i read that um on page 35
that um there was a no added saying very
small scale
and modest to reflect the size and
obviously he's highlighted
as a source as to why that might not be
the case i mean
what's your opinion on the scale of of
each one and how binding is the um
the note on the outline permission so on
the outline permission there is a note
which i think is referenced in the
officer report in terms of
um modest to reflect the scale and
character of the existing properties
nearby
in this case when officers have assessed
it and there's a mix of properties
nearby
including larger property to the south
here smaller terraced properties along
sales and road
detached properties along the holloway
and then bradshaw closed as well so in
this case
um when considering the scale of the
development and the surrounding built
form
um it's considered to be sympathetic to
the character the aryan officer's view
marvelous anyone else have any questions
points clarification
i'll have one if i may um uh our parish
council or the parish council alluded to
um emergency services vehicles and being
able to get in and out i note
that the farm rescue condition has been
removed um could you please
elaborate on that for me yes so in
response to the tracking plans and the
updated details we did we consult with
fire and rescue to make sure they were
happy that
their minimum requirements met in terms
of a fire appliance accessing the site
turning around and going back out in a
forward gear
they have confirmed that that's the case
and they've just recommended advisory
note now so the condition has fallen
away
it's no longer that could be considered
to be required marvelous thank you very
much
okay if there are no further points
points clarification debate
council jennings okay well
i don't have a problem with the house
sizes and i don't think you can use
uk average house sizes i mean if that
was the case
i mean the toilets here would be a
mansion in london
so you know you've got to you've got to
base it on local houses
and i saw plenty of large properties
when i visited the site
and my only possible issue was the
access
but after visiting the site again i was
satisfied but i guess more importantly
highways are satisfied um
i can see no material planning reasons
to go against this application
and i'd like to propose that we grant
marvelous thank you very much council
kendall please i think i'll echo exactly
what council jennings has just said
um the fact that we've got no objection
now from fire
or county highways those are the two
things that bothered me most about this
application therefore i'm happy to
second the proposal
excellent um we've got a clear direction
we have a proposal and a seconder um
unless anyone desperately wants to speak
we'll go to a vote
no okay good let's go to a vote if i
could have a show of hands then the
proposal is to grant sheriff hands for
those in favor
unanimous chairman thank you very much
it is indeed unanimous okay in that case
um committee resolves to grant
application twenty one zero zero three
five six
r e m fabulous
okay um members we're just going to take
a very brief interlude partly for a
comfort break but also while we have our
offices change over so
we'll have one minute please one minute
okay as soon as council andrew serafin
is back in a seat we will resume
proceedings
okay members uh we will dive straight
into our
next application for the evening which
is application twenty zeros three
three eight two ful that is red gables
in napton on the hill our presenting
officers ryan keith
ryan whenever you're already over to you
thank you chairman
[Music]
the application site is denoted by the
black dot on the map
plan commission is for the replacement
of an existing mono-pitched roof
with a roof um terrace
garden the existing house
is a four-story dwelling but from the
road
appears as a two story dwelling given
the topography of the
site and the surroundings
the proposed plans would build upon and
up from the existing structures already
on the site
uh to create
the walled garden in effect that you see
in front of us
the application can be seen from the
neighbors on paddock close to the bottom
of the site
looking up given the land levels
this is the dwelling as it stands and
you can obviously see
the structure at the rear which is to be
amended to create the
new walled terrace
uh these are some views obviously from
the
terrace that's there now out across to
neighbouring properties and paddock
close
and this is towards the neighbor of rose
dean
to the other side of the neighbor
and
there are some photos from the
neighboring property
looking up towards the application site
as shown here
just as a point of update
um members made a
members site visit this morning
and
we visited both neighbors at number two
and number three pad it close
to view the development thank you very
much
sorry the motion is to grant apologies
good man thank you ryan appreciate it
okay and we will go to our first speaker
who
is counselor john veazey counselor easy
do come on forward
welcome
so you'll have three minutes and we'll
give you a 30 second warning
take as much time as you need to get
yourself settled there is a button in
the middle of your microphone we'll turn
it on it will go red
and when you're ready feel free to start
the parish council wishes to object to
this application on the grounds that
will have a negative effect
on several neighbouring properties the
council considers that the site is
already over developed
and that the current proposal would be
resulting more loss of amenity to the
adjacent buildings in respect of their
gardens
the council considers that the proposal
would be overbearing
and excessively dominant and would
create a blocking mass because of the
nature of the brickwork
red gables is itself already a
replacement drilling dwelling that
compared to the original property is
massively overbearing in the space
and it was argued at the time that it
was out of character but that's
past history as we know um
the it's already been mentioned by
by um the planner that um
there's a topography issue because of
the shape of land in napton that is not
untypical
but we would like to point out as a
council that if
this was permitted then we would set a
precedent for other parts of the village
for the future potentially which may be
of
equal or greater concern since this
application
was originally posted
the council's neighborhood development
plan has been made
and we would like to draw the planning
committee's attention to
two policies in our neighborhood
development plan policy
policy 1c states that development will
be supported
and the if it is appropriate to its
surroundings and does not overshadow or
overlook adjoining properties or
otherwise is acceptable in relation
to the effect on the living conditions
on the occupiers of any
adjacent property and policy one e
states it has regard to the character
assessment in terms of scale layout
materials
and retain the local distinctiveness to
create a
sense of place on both of those two
policies we do not feel
that this application meets the
requirements thank you very much
that's obviously well within your time
thank you very much members do we have
any questions
counselor dixon first thank you chairman
uh you mentioned the ndp
can you tell me what the status has
reached out has it been made has it been
come
it's been made thank you thank you
mom it's cancer military that was my
question so it's not been adopted yet
no thank you
you're good everyone's good marvelous
council of easy you've nailed it thank
you very much indeed for your
contribution
if you wouldn't mind wiping it down
thank you that's good of you um okay
so council rock once again um i have to
speak but unfortunately isn't here so i
have another
speech to read out to you um so please
bear with me when i do that
okay so counselor rock has said as
members on the site visit have seen the
levels and
encirclement by other houses make this a
difficult location
red gables itself is a replacement
dwelling
that already rather dominates the
adjacent properties and could be argued
to be somewhat
out of character with the surroundings
this has been exasperated by a series of
works that have fully developed if not
excessively developed the plot
and largely eliminated private immunity
space this is
this and early applications appear to be
an attempt to restore that immunity
space at higher levels
that surround that surrounding dwellings
than surrounding dwellings i think i
should say
um as noted by the officer the slab wall
at this
sort of height on top of the annex is an
unusual feature
it risks detracting from the surrounding
properties by blocking mass
and overbearing features having visited
the site it is up to the members to
assess this but i would like to point
out the terms of the neighborhood
development plan
this is mentioned in references in the
report but as far as i can see not
considered in any great detail
the ndp was approved in a referendum on
the 6th of may the proposal would appear
to conflict with policy 1c
1 and 1e of the ndp once he says it must
be appropriate to its surroundings and
not overshadow or overlook adjoining
properties or otherwise be acceptable in
relation to the effect on the living
conditions on the occupiers of any
affected property
and one e says it must have regard to
the character assessment in terms of
scale layout and materials and retain
local distinctiveness to create a sense
of place i find it's difficult to see
that the application accords with these
policies and would draw members
attention to the requirements of the ndp
so recently approved by the community
that is verbatim nigel rock's
submission okay we will move to points
of clarification with our officers
councillor mills first please um thanks
michelle um
one few um how much weight
does this carry uh at the moment the
end
although it's not been adopted yet how
much weight does this carry
do we know
thank you thank you chairman if i can
help there so that my understanding is
the ndp has full weight because it had a
yes vote at the referendum
so you can make your decisions in
accordance with it it does have to go
through at a final stage of being made
by being presented to full council um
but
my understanding is that it has full
weight for decision making purposes now
it's had its referendum vote
great thank you and can i ask you may
ask another um
ryan on on the photograph can you can
you show me
was it was a view towards the one of the
properties
from from that house
right yeah that's the one um
where is that one taken from
um so this photo is taken
from me standing pretty much right
against that parapet wall
as if i was looking over
[Music]
right so
okay thank you council dixon please
thank you chairman um the two late
photographs which i think are possibly
those which were
offered today at the site visit
um i think they were possibly taken
uh from the bedroom windows
of paddock house and i don't think ryan
that you mentioned
that that was necessarily the case and i
just wondered if there is something that
you can confirm because it didn't look
to me as though they were from the
garden laptop
yeah apologies they are taken from the
first floor bedroom window
thank you if no one else has any points
of clarification we'll move to the
debate
nope let's open up the debate who would
like to kick us off
council of fielding was first um just a
very
quick one um
the you said you you met the neighbors
when this
was did they given um
were there any comments made
as you know cancer failing at site
visits we we can't debate or discuss
any of the merits of the application so
no uh in that sense no there were no
comments made
council dixon in the debates please
thank you chairman
the site visit today certainly uh gave
me an opportunity
to see and understand this uh
application the walls that we could see
around the existing we just heard for
instance at the
uh from ryan that the photograph at the
top right there uh he was up against
that parapet
and i think that parapet is to be
increased in height
on the planning application so that view
would be
more restricted if this application was
granted
we also viewed the property from
uh planet close and the gardens there
and i am of the opinion that the
property may indeed be overbearing
but that was the actual house the
proposed
development of a terrace with 1.8 metre
high
walls around it basically precludes i
think the view of anybody
on that terrace as it were seeing
into the gardens without as it were
getting on a chair or stepladder or
something
to look over the wall so i don't think
it actually impacts upon the privacy
of the neighbors as such and i think the
angle of the the view
from those gardens etc basically means
that
uh i think there's a a garage to start
off with and the the roof slope
it won't have an impact i think it's the
house that has the impact already it's
already there
what is proposed i don't think does have
an overbearing impact
and i would actually propose that it is
granted
thank you very much councilman mills
next please
thanks mr chairman yeah this certainly
is
out of place uh this and
i like council dicks i i'm i'm
probably for grant on this but uh
the whole the whole um
aspect of this is is not very pleasing
but um i can't think of a good
although i don't like it i can't think
of a good material reason to um
say no to this mr chairman thank you is
that a formal second thing yeah that's a
second
marvelous we have a proposal to grant
and it has been seconded to councillor
jennings please
no i just chucked my two pence worth in
here and i think
it hurt the extension in this
this platform is a complete eyesore um
it's i'm hoping that obviously with the
end the new ndp that this will hopefully
protect
um the village from further eyesores
like this
um but it's there now it's
one of these situations where i don't
like it but
it is what it is it's there i think that
i think uh
granting it will probably give the
people around there it'd be an eyesore
but
it gives them at least a bit more
privacy
okay thank you very much unless anyone
else wants to chip in
we will go to a vote okay in that case
the motion is to
grant um i'm gonna have to find the
application number again sorry uh grant
application twenty
zero three three eight two f u l in line
with the office of recommendation the
update sheet show of hands please for
those in favor
unanimous again mr chairman incredible
okay in that case
committee resolves to grant application
203382 ful at red gables
marvellous let's move to our final
application of the
evening which is application 203637 ful
that is rosewood in birmingham
sorry birmingham rhode in henley and
arden it's a long way from stratford
birmingham isn't it
and henley and arden um our president
governor as it is once again rhino keith
ryan whenever you are ready over to
you
thank you chairman the application site
is donated by the black dot
on the map in front of you playing
permission is
for a proposed first floor extension
to a side two-story rear extension and a
single story
extension to the rear
uh this is the existing dwelling uh in
front of you
and these are the proposed um
alterations and extensions and you can
see the side extension
and the rear alterations as well
obviously a few from the front and some
from the rear of the property
and looking towards other neighboring
properties
the main issue is green belts there is
an approved
extant permission on the application
site for a side extension and a
two-story rear extension
and a previously refused application for
a similar development i've proposed
here the motion is to refuse the
application
on the cumulative um
volume over and above the original
dwelling in regards to green belt
thank you
thank you very much ryan um we will have
our first speaker
who is mr honey mr honey good evening
and welcome
we're just bringing up your uh
presentation
feel free to take your mask off
once we're there and you're ready to go
three minutes 30 seconds
before the end and as soon as you're
ready to start you can start
which is bear with us minor technical
glitch the joys of modern tech
okay presumably you have a number of
slides so you will be saying next slides
and so on and so forth we'll make sure
that gets done so as i say three minutes
30 second morning whenever you're ready
uh thank you for allowing me to speak to
support our planning application
we moved to henley and arden for me to
take up a post as a consultant emt
surgeon at south warwickshire nhs trust
next slide please
we chose rosewood on birmingham road uh
due to the lovely long garden which is
perfect for our
young family as you can see in the photo
here we have the
probably the largest and longest garden
in the row of houses
but probably the smallest footprint of a
house
next slide please
the house gave us a few problems to
solve uh the three good size bedrooms
one tiny box room which you may be able
to see there in the middle at the back
not large enough for a double bed so
difficult to have any
any guests to stay over a family of four
two girls one bathroom just isn't going
to work for us
there's also a wasted unusable storage
space on the left hand side of the
sloping roof
which we unable to use next slide please
so we began our planning journey after a
couple of years living in the house
working out how it would work best for
us
with the aim of improving it for our
family
so we got some permitted development
plans from our architect as you can see
here um they gave us a lot more space
but they looked
awful um and the visual impact was not
very nice at all
um we chose the house on of rosewood
because of the aesthetics
there's something appealing that they
all look fairly similar with slight
differences
and we wanted to make an extension
similar to others
similar scale and size next slide please
so this was the permitted development
that we were given
a couple of years ago um it's almost
identical at the front view that we're
asking for now probably bigger in that
one that was permitted
and we've kept the art deco influence
with the two-story extension there and
what we wanted though was
um and i will show you the one
that i'm going to propose next slide
please
so we're lucky to be in the green belt
we've got fields both front and back and
it's important to us to keep the
openness
without making a negative visual impact
next slide please
so here are 10 of the 12 houses so
there's five here five on the next slide
in the row each have had extension to
the left side over the garage
um similar to the ones that we propose
some of them much larger in fact
uh we've got a support of councillor
matt jennings parish council
and from our neighbours we're making it
function for a young family it's not
about making an enormous
soulless building 30 seconds next slide
that's the and then another slide please
that's another five
um that's our proposed plan the main
difference is that we wanted a
small uh kitchen diner at the back to
make
family living so that we can um have
meals together
uh next slide please i'm gonna need to
ask you just to summarize and
and yeah the last two so our next door
neighbor at the top left there they've
got a
similar extension and it's 58 increase
in volume ours is less than that
the other side on the right hand side
that's a huge extension five meters
we're not going as far as that
and that's 903 meters cubed
so to conclude um we just want to make a
nice family home we're not going for
anything enormous
we've taken uh advice of the parish
council reduced the
the height of the roof line and we just
want something similar to our neighbours
and a nice family home that we all enjoy
thank you
thank you very much we have one slightly
over but i've allowed that because
obviously with the technical
uh constraints that we have okay do we
have any questions
uh counselor and servant first please ah
not understanding
um support from your neighbours are
those from either side of your property
yeah both um we've spoken to people
obviously we don't want to upset our
neighbours we get on very well
uh and they're they're very happy for us
to to go for a
what we think is a modest and similar
size
extension to everyone else thank you
cancer fielding please well
any idea when this property was built
basically a line of houses were built
are they same developer
yes yeah it's i think just pre-war
pre-second world war so 1930s
so they're on a slightly smaller scale
than
modern requirements yeah
okay if we've got any other questions
for our
council fleming just a quick one you
said the parish council
or somebody spoke to you about the the
height of the roof line
is that to make your extension
subservient to the main house yes
that's the kind of a rule that we all
have so i'm just checking that's what it
was yeah so it was interesting the first
uh permitted and the one that was
granted 18 months ago
there was no issue really with the roof
line but we listened to the parish
council and made it subservient
because you know we want to keep
everybody happy okay fine thank you very
much
okay if there are no further questions
mr thank you very much for your
contribution this evening thank you
if you wouldn't mind giving the table a
quick like that'd be lovely and then we
will call cancer jennings forward
thank you very much council jennings to
please come on down
i would offer you an extra 30 seconds in
the interest of fairness but i don't
think you're going to need all the time
are you
should hopefully be able to race through
this quite quickly i've got some photos
which may break it out a bit but i shall
let's bring the photos up and then as
soon as we've got them
um and when you're ready you can start
okay far away when you're ready okay
first of all good evening committee
and this is a row of art deco houses 11
11 of them on the outskirts of henley
they all originally looked exactly the
same
um but over the years they've all been
extended in different ways
um it looks like some of them have
almost doubled if you look at the photo
which is up at the moment
um this is house number one if i can
if i can quickly flick through the flick
through the house photos
again has two three four
five six so they're all very very
large but this is rosewood which is the
smallest out of all of them
and i think here perception is
of the size is very important um
i think to it's important important to
understand this property has been
granted planning
and the extant commission which they can
start a two-story extension tomorrow
if they wish could you go on to the next
extra photo extent one
it's currently at the top is what
they're what they've got
at the bottom left they can build that
tomorrow
on the on the bottom right is what
they're proposed this is the visual
from the front so it looks
from what i can how i view it
what they're actually proposing looks
smaller than
what they've already got permission for
so if we go on to extant 2
now this photo shows what at the top
left
what they've got permission for
so and that's fine so the only bit which
we're really discussing here is the
extra bit onto their kitchen which is
which is a ground floor um it's not
visible
from anywhere um
obviously what i did was i went around
to the the back of the property it went
down there
went down the lane to see if it was
visible and if you could go on to the
next photo
and all you can see is seven foot high
fences
hedges you can't see any of the breers
of any of these properties
and it's it's been stated that the
increase in volume will amount to a
disproportionate
cumulative addition and be inappropriate
development in the green belt
well this this is based on a percentage
increase
of 61 percent but have to remember house
number five
has had a 58 increase in 2018
so we're talking about two percent
difference so i'm sort of wondering if
it being 59 would that be okay
60 would that be okay but i mean we
recently approved a 72 percent
increase in the green belt um just down
the road in metal bra green
why because it was proportionate to the
plot
um there's going to be no urban sprawl
here
it's not going to link up henry to
lapworth anytime soon
um it's not visible from the road it's
not visible from
anywhere apart from if you have a
satellite photo
um i see no harm
and i appreciate is up to up to your
judgment but taking into account all the
circumstances
hopefully you'll see the extension is
proportionate
now obviously this is a very important
word proportionate especially when
compared to the sizes of the other
houses in this row
and if again if you remember house
number one the size of that
it looks enormous and there's been no
parish objection
no highways objection no conservation
objection not even
one from the cpre and they normally
object to everything
normally in these circumstances one of
the neighbors will object in this case
there are no objections
and they're both supported and i hope
you'll regard this application as
appropriate
and decide to grant that's
thank you very much indeed members to
have any questions for councillor
jennings please
counseling sorry it should be a question
i asked the owner
but is this sort of a modernization of
the property bringing it up to date
i don't know yes um do we have any other
questions for councillor jennings
no in that case council thank you very
much let's move to points clarification
counselor dixon first please
thank you chairman ryan um
i think the increase in the in the
volume that we're looking at here
compared to
the extent permission is on the ground
floor kitchen extension
would pd rights uh provide the
opportunity
to build rearwards from an original wall
therefore going back possibly eight
meters from what was there presumably
pre-war in the 1930s and therefore
if we were not favoring this application
tonight
the owner could in actual fact develop
under pd rights at the back
therefore would pd rights present a
fallback position which we ought to be
aware of
so firstly with the
extent permission sorry um
pd rights were removed as part of the
application
and the issue is we can't look
just at that single story rear extension
we have to take the whole amount into
consideration
because even though on plan they look
like three
different elements you can't construct
them independently of each other
so yes if you refuse permission
tonight they can carry out what they've
got approval for
and then go from there
okay do we have any other points of
clarification from members
no let's open up the debate who would
like to kick us off
councillor kendall was first thank you
um
well quick um i think we've looked at
these sort of things in the past
and to be blunt i don't consider the
proposal cause as a significant harm to
the
opens of the character of the green belt
i think the at the extent
permission is already there the extent
permission's already there and i don't
view the
the kitchen element to be anywhere near
proportional uh sorry anyway
near significant enough uh in terms of
impacting the openness of the
of the greenbelt so although my wording
is a bit
dodgy because i'm tired i'm happy to
propose that we grant the
recommendation actually i think what you
were trying to say was you don't
consider it to be disproportionate in
its increase
perfect thank you councillor dixon
thank you chairman i will second that
proposal
oh thank you very much cancer mills yes
um yeah i think they've said it almost
these are lovely art deco houses um
i've also admired them in the past
driving past and
went and visited last week and um
i can't say there's a problem with this
mr chairman um
as all the other houses have had uh
extensions um
i i'm going for grant on this mr
chairman thank you
okay just to summarize what's been said
then very quickly i'll do my best to do
this
um ultimately the proposal is to grant
and the reason we're going against
officer's recommendation is committee do
not consider
the increase in scale to in size to be
disproportionate to the
extent permission but also the built
form
along the same road is that correct
marvelous
we need to consider some conditions um
cancer phone i can see
you indicating is it going to be
material
the precedence is round about this subs
that i go ahead with what everyone else
has said
okay do we need to we do need to have
some conditions do you have a list of
conditions for us please ryan
um standard
three years for implementation um
in accordance to plans
materials as submitted
and that would be enough um
okay pd rights still being
removed if we look to grant this
application
we could remove pd rights like we did on
the extent permission
but again we would fail the
firstly they
by granting this permission they
couldn't extend
their application under pd
from the rear elevation so it would be
um
pointless to do so and we'd fail the
test and removing pd rights
okay so just so i get this right in my
head because we've already
removed the pd rights under the extant
permission
we don't need to do that under this one
even though this one would replace the
extent one
yeah because essentially if we remove
pd rights we wouldn't have sufficient
justification to do so
because the argument is not there
anymore
than on the previous application because
on the
sorry on the previous application it got
to a volume increase that we were happy
with
and removed pd rights and we had the
justification that they'd extended
to an amount that we would then control
it by
planning um so it wouldn't be needed
given given this this application
replaces
the extant one i think we can still
apply that
same condition on the basis that
um this is slightly larger again yeah
though to the extent
of that we're comfortable is the is the
volume
expansion i think it's still pertinent
to remove the pd rights
um i would agree
but i would agree that we would look to
remove
class a like the original x stamp
but only to extensions and not
alterations
um because then that would be reasonable
for the homeowner
to carry out alterations as you know
replacement windows and
research so the previous removal was
just for part a
yeah so it's i i think what i'm trying
to get to and i think my members the
members would agree
we want to maintain the same pe removal
yeah um if it's just party that's fine
as long as it's maintained
yeah okay you happy very happy you don't
want to add any other conditions
okay if we're all happy then we'll move
to a vote um so
uh the proposal is to grant application
twenty zero three six
three seven full inline not in line with
officer recognition sorry for the
reasons given
were the conditions that we've just had
could i have a show of hands for those
in favor
unanimous chairman i think that's a
record unanimous on everything
in that case um committee resolves to
grant application 2003 637
f u l we do have
two more items uh to consider for those
eagle-eyed of you an eagle-eared you
will have noticed that i
omitted the minutes at the start of the
meeting so we do need to do that now
so could i have show of hands everyone
has agreed minutes and i think
with the exception of cancer fielding
who wasn't here that would be unanimous
so that's agreed and then we also need
to consider the start times
future meetings i'm going to propose
that we maintain six o'clock seconded by
cancer kendall shirt quick share hands
unanimous again nailed it um okay in
that case there's no virgin business so
i declare the meeting close thank you
very much everybody
you